thank you Tim thank you all being here I
have a word of welcome I have some
necessary thanks and I'm gonna tell you
what we have to accomplish by tomorrow
afternoon so you can all get ready tim
is an excellent employee and he adds
elevation to the college so I think
Chris Batchelder who gave for him a kind
of a nerdy speech I thought and that
Chris is the trustee so it means that
worked for him but before that he worked
for me he was the vice president for
marketing at the college and his claim
to distinction is the girls in his life
the two I know best are his wife who's
the CEO of Popeyes Chicken and one of
the most successful CEOs in the country
and his daughter Katie a graduate of the
college who's now big-wheel on the
editorial page of the opinion page of
The Wall Street Journal
I have to introduce to you to Newt one
of us not here we have two new trustees
today and one of them's not here so who
cares who he is
actually it's a very great Steve Stevens
who's married to the beautiful Angie
from Little Rock Arkansas and I'm from
Arkansas which means that Steve and I
are now forming a coalition to efface
the memory of the Clintons from our
state
but you know we were talking today Steve
and I I'm not sure the Clintons need us
to do that and the other one is here if
I admit I'm sure he says where's this
David Darrell here yeah yeah stand up
David and his wife Ann Sam still here
and left so welcome them to the board of
trustees of the college it is the
greatest governing board the board of
trustees of Hillsdale College is a
hundred and seventy two years old and
every board meeting begins with a
document a reading from a document that
founded the college that is that old and
we set off on our deliberations every
time understanding that that says what
we're supposed to do and so we just try
to do it and that what that's what makes
us look so crazy but it's also true that
that's why they're delightful to work
for now our Philip and Mary Netley here
Diane are the hairs died in here Phillip
okay you can sit down and I'm not ready
for you yet so I have to do a duty that
is that is in the province of the
college president properly understood
Dianne Phillip is the vice president for
student affairs she's a very important
woman she's a awesome woman and then she
has a daughter named Marissa just a son
named Joe who's starting in our freshman
class next year gonna be the kicker on
our football team but Marissa is a
graduate and a wonderful young woman and
she is going to marry soon Christopher
Netley a captain of Marines away and his
parents are Philip and Mary whom Diane
discovers
Phil is a veteran of Vietnam thank you
for your service and who's a great fan
of Hillsdale College for some time and
my point and I have to do it in front of
all of you your witnesses is that sir I
love and admire you very much mr.
but I have to warn you if your son is
not good to Marissa I will have to harm
him stand up and be recognized sir
and I'm not gonna introduce ion who is a
friend of mine except Tim's gonna do
that but I do want to state my
grievances against her she's a heroic
woman she's you're gonna if you don't
know her you're gonna love her
but she just pointed me very badly
because she was about to enroll in our
college and I was gonna give her
whatever education she wanted for free
and then she'd married this deadbeat
world famous historian Niall Ferguson
and he's really great too and they've
had a son now and so I'm forgiving her
especially because she just told me she
is gonna come and spend some time in the
college in the near future and you're
all witnesses to that you think that's a
good idea
also I'm a little aggrieved because she
gave a better speech at the branding
prices than I did but I can put up with
that so now what are we going to
accomplish so we have to get our boots
on we have to get our game face on right
we're gonna talk about some public
policy issues we're just right now doing
an online course on public policy does
anyone else believe that public policy
is the most boring subject on earth I do
I can't bear it
except when I think what it is because
you know public comes from a Latin word
that means the people and policy comes
from a Latin and a Greek word the Greek
word means either the city or also we
get the name police from it public
policy implies force and of course we're
in the middle of a great drama and what
this drama is to decide is whether this
country will continue to be governed by
there its people or whether they will be
overwhelmed by those who make public
policy I'm going to talk about education
tomorrow and that is surely the bleakest
subject on the face of the earth on the
other hand it's the greatest subject on
the face of the earth we need to
understand what's changed about that and
about each of the things there four of
them that we're going to talk about why
is it that regimes that would brutalize
their women ion has attempted to be done
to her but she's too brave and
persistent and stubborn why would we not
say in plain language what those regimes
are why would we send our children to
schools that cost more for them except
when they teach them things that are not
so
why would we do that when the
alternative is available and cheaper why
would we think that man is the virus on
earth not the lord of creation-- but the
ax sailor of it the purpose being to
control man to protect the environment
what do those ideas come from we should
understand that and we should understand
the threat that they pose we will argue
I will argue tomorrow about education
that the essential threat is the
dehumanization of humankind the
abolition of human beings but also we
just remembered tonight and tomorrow and
for the rest of our lives the reason we
should be hopeful is it nice right I
mean max our and Julia y know who's
working here they're both students of
mine and we wanted somebody smart and
good-looking but we couldn't find a boy
so we brought mat on the other hand
Julia's both those things right but
what's our relationship I'm an old man
running the big institution and talking
to you I'm their teacher like pasterinos
sitting back there and all them right it
is a natural and a beautiful
relationship and it will orient your
life when you see it it could change
everything about you to do the job of
teaching just like learning which are
the same job it turns out so I wanted us
to remember that we should understand
what's going on and that that is
frightening and we should be hopeful
about it because we are living in an
exciting time
the debate is fundamental and there's a
chance to do something about it what
better way to live than live in that
attempt thank you for coming
thank you very much president Arne our
next speaker is making her second
appearance at a Hillsdale College event
she first spoke at a national leadership
seminar in Santa Monica California in
2009 following the publication of her
memoir infidel yes she was controversial
then to ayaan Hirsi Ali was born in
Mogadishu Somalia as a young girl in
order to escape an arranged marriage she
sought asylum in the Netherlands where
she became a citizen is while working in
factories and as a maid she learned
Dutch and eventually earned her MA in
political science from the University of
Leiden it was while she was serving as
an elected member of the Dutch
parliament that the film director Theo
van Gogh was murdered van Gogh directed
our speakers film submission whose theme
was the oppression of women under Islam
two years later she tangled with the
Dutch government over her citizenship
status and had to resign from Parliament
I think it's what the Liberals call
blaming the victim though she was
vindicated in the end she decided to
move to the United States well we're
glad to have her and I'm happy to tell
you that in 2013 she became an American
citizen congratulations
she is now a fellow with the future of
diplomacy project at the Belfer Center
for Science and International Affairs
and a visiting fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute in 2007 she founded
the aah a Foundation which focuses on
violence against women and girls her
most recent book which was published
just eight days ago is heretic why Islam
needs a reformation now please please
welcome thank you please welcome a
courageous fellow American ayaan Hirsi
Ali
now ladies and gentlemen tell me if
that's not daunting thank you so much
for that warm welcome thank you so much
for taking me and making me a part of
your community I love and have loved my
experience of being an American and I
share with Larry the optimism we live in
challenging times that is absolutely
true
but because we are challenged and as
Larry said and thank you Tim for those
wonderful and kind and welcoming words
but as Larry said it is when we are
challenged as individuals as communities
as Nations that we actually get to find
out whether our principles and our ideas
are solid or whether they are founded on
sand and what I love about being an
American and Larry I will come to
Hillsdale so that you and your
institution can give me and people like
me really educate me on the ins and outs
of the Constitution but what I really do
love about our American founding
principles is that they are not founded
on sand they're enduring if we stand up
to the challenge Thank You Larry for
doing this I want to thank the Hillsdale
community for doing that I want to thank
you all especially those of you who
retired I just sat next to a gentleman
from Ohio me who is 83 years old and
he's still going
and there's another gentleman John
Donnelly who came to me now and he said
to me give them hell and that is what I
am here to do I think that this
community for me may be preaching to the
choir maybe it is preaching to the choir
maybe we share not only the fact that we
value our founding principles but maybe
we also share the desire and the urge to
fight for that and to leave something
for our children and grandchildren it
was July 24 1992 when I took a train I
was 22 years old I took a train from
Bonn in Germany to Amsterdam the
Netherlands I asked for asylum like so
many people are doing today in Europe a
couple of days later and in processing
that I was sent to a place called voila
where I that would be my first place of
contact and I was asked to sit on a
bench in the waiting room and I sat
waiting I'm a black woman I was
originally born in Somalia I have a
headscarf tightly wound around my head I
look as alien as alien can be and as I'm
sitting on that bench waiting not
knowing what's going to happen next a
very tall man in uniform comes toward me
and I'm scared I'm terrified because
where I came from and I came from
several places
at that moment ten years prior I lived
in Kenya and before that in Ethiopia and
before that in Saudi Arabia and before
that in Somali so I'm 22 years old I'm
sitting on that bench and this gentleman
is coming toward me and he is in uniform
and I'm terrified of uniforms because
uniforms in all those countries that I
lived in mean in one word terror people
in uniform come they take your relatives
away they burn your homes down they
shoot you people in uniform representing
the government that is the muscle of the
government when I was growing up meant
that you feared them don't cross them
and this gentleman is walking toward me
and I'm sitting there and I'm thinking
okay it's over I was escaping a forced
marriage I had offended my parents and
my extended family I was at that moment
feeling steeped in guilt and shame
thinking I had offended my god I had
done everything wrong and now here comes
this man in uniform and only bad things
are going to happen and as he gets
closer and my heart is thumping in my
chest he says would you like a cup of
tea or a cup of coffee
for me that was the moment that I
encountered the rule of law and that
changed it stuck with me it's changed
the way I look at things and I became
and I think what it did is in me it
sparked it sparked a curiosity who are
these people why are they being so
generous to us what is this government
about and asking these questions led me
to years into my presidents in the
Netherlands two and a half years to
think I want to apply to the University
of Leiden I had shopped for universities
I found some universities that said to
me it's all student-centered
you mark your own grades and I said no
to that I went I saw some that I thought
one I mean the curriculum was so broad
it didn't I didn't think I would learn
anything
I found the University of Leiden it was
the most demanding they offered the most
demanding program and I wanted that
demanding program and when I went to the
admissions officer and I'm a refugee I'm
speaking in broken Dutch she says to me
I don't think that you taking practical
political science is practical for you
go and do something else like accounting
I told her I just was curious about what
made this country what it is she's the
admissions officer and she said
curiosity will not get you a job you
need at the end of this program to have
a job and I told her I already had a job
I had worked as a cleaner I had served
in this factory places where you pack
things I at that point was making more
money than most of the other students
because I was working as a translator in
top
if I wanted to make money I could make
money what I really wanted to know that
was that part of me that was Henry was
why is this world different from the
world that I came from and I got
admitted and in those years I learned a
number of things I never would have
learned I learned about Western
civilization I learned about the history
in detail of the Netherlands I learned
about all those religious wars
everything was an introduction there
were such courses as psychology and
public administration he talked about
policy I have to say that was quite
boring but as time moves on and I'm
living in the Netherlands and you know
I'm able to deal every time I learn
something and a question in my head is
answered I'm confronted with my own
cognitive dissonance
if you can put question marks on all the
thinkers in Western civilization if
everything is a theory that's not a hard
science and even if hard sciences start
first with a theory hypothesis and you
learn all about falsifying and verifying
and in Leiden when I asked what about
religion what about Christianity it was
also a hypothesis so if that was a
hypothesis what about Mohammed then but
in those years between 1995 and 2000 I
did not mentally explore an answer to
that I didn't want to do it because I
was scared terrified of the outcome and
living there I was liking it
I threw off my headscarf and all the
other garments that to me were told of
modesty I assimilated into Dutch society
I made friends I lived with my boyfriend
we were planning we had a household
together we were planning to have
children together so I was thoroughly
assimilated I was at that point a Dutch
woman not just because my document said
you are Dutch but because in values in
culture in spirit I had completely
assimilated and then came 9/11 and
everybody was trying to explain when I
say everybody I mean the newspaper
commentators the academia the
politicians everybody was trying to
explain what just happened
and not only that why in the Netherlands
a group of young men in a place called
area where I had resided and I had found
the greatest amount of kindness why
these young men was celebrating and
rejoicing at the fall of the Twin Towers
I gave them my two cents as evidence
came in from not what was said about the
perpetrators but what the perpetrators
said themselves I said I recognize this
this could have been me in 1985 1986
when I was a teenager
I believed in these things I understand
why those young men are Jubilees ting
it's in our religion this is what we've
been taught
I was described in to this day I am
described as an individual who is
traumatized regardless of how much
evidence comes up my trauma is supposed
to be enduring if that's what Western
intellectuals most of them liberals but
not all of them if they want to explain
this phenomenon away by not linking
Islam to the violence it motivates then
that's their choice but what were
Muslims saying in doing and back then in
2001 the Muslims that were communicating
with me were members of my family
members of my extended family and the
Muslim community in the Netherlands and
about 99 percent of them were describing
me as a traitor as a heretic as infidel
that was an infidel was a term that just
kept coming over and over and over again
the kindest and most compassionate among
them was saying to me along the way
something happened to you
psychologically maybe that's because you
lost your sister you need to go into
therapy but Freud is not going to wash
away critical thinking psychology is not
going to do it sociology is not going to
do it at one point you have to look at
yourself in the mirror and you have to
ask those questions that I asked myself
in mid 2002
is Mohamad my moral guide and I couldn't
escape that question anymore knowing
what I knew about Mohammed and I decided
no he cannot be my moral guide I'm not
going to use the terms that came to my
mind even though don't Donnelly asked me
to be as politically incorrect as
possible but I did use them I did use
that those words and you will see in the
interviews that I gave and in the books
that I have written exactly what I was
thinking at that point now fast forward
fast forward this is in 2001 and in 2001
2002 2003 it's not only in the
Netherlands or in different countries in
Europe it's also here in the United
States where the best and the brightest
supposedly are trying to explain to us
what happened and what does it have to
do with Islam and that process generates
so much information so many scholars and
commentators and experts gets to have
their say and those who come across the
same evidence that I saw are
consistently set aside as racists as
bigots or traumatized and irrational and
in 2010 following this what to me seemed
this block this monolithic monolithic
block of Muslims and thinking after
every terrorist attack that is done in
the name of Islam why I know there are
so many
good Muslims why don't they just come
out and say what it is why not take
advantage of the fact that we have the
freedom of speech freedom of press
freedom of conscience here in the West
in Europe and in America why they're not
coming out not saying these things there
were a few scattered individuals who
were doing that but we want a movement
we were nothing to write home about and
so in 2010 I came to the conclusion okay
there are good Muslims good Muslims just
like you and me they're not interested
in killing people in the name of their
religion they're not interested in
mistreating women they're not
anti-semitic they're not anti-american
or anti anything they just want to lead
a comfortable life but they also want to
be spiritual so in 2010 in nomads I
advised them to become Christians
because I thought if you want to believe
in a god and you are a good person and
you need a benign God and it's better to
become a Christian and I wrote an open
letter to the Pope back then saying well
here is your flock here are these
wonderful people and they're caught
between these tools convert them to
Christianity that's what I said in 2010
because in 2010 I had no idea I didn't
see any evidence to suggest that Islam
could be reformed because even the
Muslim populations in free countries
that did not fear persecution were
refusing to ask the questions that I had
been asking and you can't reform a
religion you can't reform an institution
you can't reform anything if you refuse
to ask the necessary critical questions
then the Arab Spring happens again fast
forward and as its unfolding I am now
seeing evidence that is people in large
numbers coming out not only not only to
depose the dictators that had tortured
them and persecuted them for decades but
many of them are young and they are men
and they're women and they're mostly
women and they're saying they're saying
we identify as Muslim but we don't want
Sharia law if you have a moment go back
to those images google it go back in
that time and what you will see is that
some people the majority are against the
dictatorships but when the dictators
fall in Tunisia in Egypt in other places
in you then especially in Tunisia in
Egypt you then see the next phase where
the Muslim Brotherhood comes on and they
want to impose Sharia law on them
Islamic law and now there is a second
plot a second wave of protests and
that's that second wave of protest
inspired me to write heretic to think
that all my goodness I wasn't the only
one who had those question marks it's
not only a scattered few look at these
numbers that are saying no to Sharia I
linked that to the demonstrations in
2009 in Iran what did you see a lot of
young people protesting what were they
demonstrating against the Islamic
Republic
they had lived with Sharia law since
1979 they experienced it they were
subjected if they were women to be
covered from head to toe they were
chased out of the public life is the
regime the government was dictating to
women this is what you have to wear
there were women who were taken to
prison because they were nail polish or
lipstick the Islamic Republic those
young people were demonstrating and they
were demonstrating and most of them were
actually the women were wearing nail
polish and makeup and they were dressed
in jeans and they were not saying death
to America they were not saying death to
Israel so watching all of that and much
more that I can't bore you with tonight
I thought okay let me revisit the
question of reformation
is it really possible to reform Islam
but in order to do that then
conceptually you have to separate Islam
as a doctrine from Muslims Islam Islam
as a doctrine as a political doctrine
with a religious component is one thing
and from Islam and the legacy of
Muhammad and the Jews prudence of the
scholars over the centuries who are
faithful to Muhammad you can derive a
doctrine that is political first and
foremost with some religious components
we can understand that and this is what
I learned in Leiden that you can
understand a doctrine by trying to find
the basic fundamentals who is the
founder what was his agenda
what did he accomplish what did he leave
behind so that work is there that's the
doctrine but now how are you going to
deal with the diversity of Muslims we
are told by the United Nations and other
organizations that counts people I don't
know how they do in that one-fifth of
humanity is Muslim so how do you deal
with that now if you go back to the
doctrine what you're going to find out
is that Muhammad in Mecca actually
proposed a religion and the religious
aspects was stressed more than the
political aspects even though he called
on the meccans to abandon their gods and
join his but he didn't get much traction
he goes to Medina he becomes a warrior
that moment by the way it's called the
Hydra it's the moment that Muhammad
moves to go and settle a new place and
in that new place he creates a militia
an insurgency and then he starts to
fight the Meccans fast and to his great
surprise he wins and today if you want
to understand Muslim diversity you're
going to find fast two sorts of Muslims
one sort invoke Mohammed in Medina they
invoke the Hydra they invoke the
conquests they invoke his philosophy of
perseverance be patient when you need to
be patient fight when you need to fight
you'll find another type of Muslim
when they invoke Mohammed they invoke
Muhammad in Mecca they talk about
looking after the orphans praying and
fasting and big communal aspects that we
today in the United States of America
and I think in Europe and the rest of
the Western world we would describe that
as religion or religious and as I'm
working through the framework of how to
write this book I think I now have a
mecca category and I have a Medina
category but what about those people I
saw demonstrating against Sharia what
about some of those scholars like ali
abdul razzaq student of al-azhar who
opposed the idea of the caliphate
Mahmood muhammad aha of sudan who in
fact pushed for a mecca agenda and said
that the medina everything that happened
in medina was to be seen contextual what
about these people and they didn't fit
in the Medina category because they
don't have a Medina agenda they in fact
reject the Medina agenda they're not as
passive and apathetic as the mecca group
they're a group unto themselves they are
the modifiers they are the reformers
they are asking critical questions and
they're coming to conclusions that are
consequential the modifiers so there we
have Islam or in all its legacy part of
it religious but really a great part of
it political and here you have 1/5 of
humanity and I think that that
classification Medina Mecca modifier is
a better classification than what we've
been using since 9/11 since 9/11 we've
been talking about radicals moderates
extremists fundamentalists but that
doesn't get you anywhere
why doesn't get it gets you anywhere
because you never get to talk about
Muhammad
and Mohammed is the guy that all Muslims
have to emulate if they are truly Muslim
to be a Muslim is to confess there's no
god but Allah and Muhammad is His
Messenger and what you do when you
emulate Muhammad and what you emphasize
is key its key now going through that I
think okay so what would these modifiers
if they had things their way and if they
were to prepare a pitch a sales pitch to
the Mecca Muslims what would they want
to change modify reform in Islam its
five key things and now I'm looking at
the time I'm okay
so the first one the first one is
following the Prophet Muhammad and the
Quran like you follow the GPS that
brought you here so the people with a
Medina agenda will constantly invoke and
constantly say and Muhammad said and the
Koran said and the verse and so as a
person use I don't agree with that
you're an infidel you are an apostate
that's the Medina agenda and so the
modifier will have to say we need to
change our attitude to the Quran and to
Muhammad I'm not saying we edit the
Koran the attitude to these two key
factors the man and the book needs to
change number two if you look at the
people with the Medina agenda they
emphasize and overemphasize and in my
view exaggerate life after death they
say life after death is far more
important than life before death as a
consequence Islam as a political
doctrine is turned into a death cult
because young people would rather not
invest in school or in their careers or
in their community or in their vocations
but it's all about what can I get in
return from God
once I die and how do I want to die
number three Sharia law there's this
complex framework of divine law that
Mohammed left in Medina he he started to
develop it in Medina it wasn't there
before
Sharia law and it governs everything and
then it gets developed even after his
death by all the caliphs that succeed
him and it is about exactly what this
community deplores the most it is a way
of controlling the individual mind the
relationship between individuals the
relationship between the husband and the
wife the relationship between the ruler
and the ruled the relationship between
those who believe and those who don't it
controls all of that it controls the
economy and the military so Sharia law
is something that I think that the
modifiers need to unite around
repudiating rejecting modifying
there's a little-known concept called
commanding right and forbidding wrong
and what that does is it makes the
believing Muslim turns him into a
vigilante or her so that you keep the
herd inside you ask a question you are a
woman you drop your head scuff and
you're a fellow believer your own sister
says look at you
put that back on again you're
associating with the infidels turn your
back to that person you can't invest
your money in here because of usury so
it's not as if you as a believer choose
to follow the rules or not to follow the
rules the fellow a believer constantly
reminds you of it what does that make
you think in terms of totalitarianism
commanding right and forbidding wrong
and then there's jihad holy war against
the infidel the Muslim that was Mohammed
in Medina is not here only to become a
Muslim and get on with his life or her
life the Muslim was created by God and
chosen by God to bring the entire world
to Islam first by fair means through
Dawa and then through jihad and I raise
your hand if you know the time Dawa one
two three a smattering of hands in a
room of about 550 people you don't know
raise your hand if you know jihad almost
everyone almost everyone and yet I think
Dawa is far more dangerous than jihad
because jihad is dower
by other means and the modifying Muslims
if they've been paying attention and if
they've allowed their minds to ask these
questions know that these five key
things need to change
now in terms of our national security so
that is reforming Islam modifying Islam
the confrontation between the medina
Muslims and the modifies and whatever
shape the Mecca Muslims take that is an
internal struggle internal relationship
within the house of Islam but for all
for those of us I've stepped out of it I
think of myself more as an American
citizen I'm more loyal to the this the
Constitution of America than anything
else so for those of us I'm an infidel
an apostate and I'm proud of it
but for those of us on the outside what
do we what do we need to know we need to
know what that doctrine is we need to
know who Muhammad was and what he did
and why the medina Muslims invoke him we
need to know the Medina agenda we need
to know what their ways not only what
jihad is but what Dao is we need to know
who is pushing the Medina agenda
obviously in the headlines in newspapers
and on television we learn about Isis
al-qaeda Boko Haram al-shabaab and we
debate why or whether or not they are
connected to Islam but what we fail to
do is to see the Medina agenda that is
pushed gradually through our schools in
our neighborhoods without necessarily
using violence by using our institutions
to sabotage our miserable house with our
own hands that's the agenda we need to
be aware of that's what we need to know
and political correctness doesn't serve
that we need to start understanding that
classification not all Muslims are
terrorists not all Muslim men are bad
not all Muslims are our enemies but we
need to be able to tell the difference
and we can't tell the difference unless
we educate ourselves on the doctrine and
now I'm going to give leave the rest of
the time for you to ask questions and I
promise you I'm gonna stay here until
all your questions are done
Don did i disappoint you so we have some
time for some questions please raise
your hand if you have a question yes as
we accept immigrants what should be the
interrogation to determine whether
they're here to integrate and accept our
rule of law or Harbor the sentiments of
Sharia law realizing that we may need
labor that we may want to have open
borders to encourage immigration because
it has benefited the country to some
extent although at the moment we're
questioning that what is it that we
should interrogate in order to assure
that we are having folks that will
embrace who we as Americans cherish as
important to being an American thank you
for that incredibly important question
which i think is in the mind or on the
mind of every American who's paying
attention I was up until almost 1:00
a.m. last night communicating with my
network about rescuing a woman I'm not
going to tell you where from but she's
in a Muslim country she gave an
interview talking about high development
how she believed who her family is and
how she no longer believes in Islam that
whole critical thinking process members
of our community saw this
and the threats on her life began it's
women like that and it's not only women
there are also men I think if you have
been following any what's going on in
some of these countries there were the
Bangladeshi bloggers and there's still
some of those bloggers not only in
Bangladesh there in Saudi Arabia there
in Syria there in Iraq they're
everywhere and these are people
individuals who are taking the time to
think through these things like I did
and some of them reach the conclusion
that yes the principles of freedom that
dignify the human being and establish
and preserve the rule of law as superior
to Sharia law these are the people that
we should be giving refuge these are the
people we should embrace these are the
people we should partner with and I know
that there's so many of them in the
closet because coming out of the closet
means risking death real and present
danger and I think that is the criteria
we need to make if there are young
children if there are vulnerable women
and vulnerable men and we feel we
morally obligated to rescue them and we
should negotiate with them that they
have to abandon those values and embrace
ours and if they don't it's a choice we
don't rescue them that comes across as
being extremely hard and cruel on crass
but if you don't do that
we're going to get what is what you see
unfolding in Europe which is a mindless
senseless unplanned immigration
thank you Miss Ellie I plan to download
your book on my Kindle tonight but last
night I finished Robert Spencer's book
the infant infidels complete guide to
the Quran in so stunning the book I read
the Quran it's also on my Kindle in
light of surah number 9 how can we
reform Islam again I repeat it is not up
to us the infidels to reform Islam it's
up to Muslims to do it and it's great to
watch this confrontation between the
medina Muslims and the modifiers I think
we need to empower the modifiers but in
the light of surah 9 or chapter 9 and we
first of all have to learn what it says
about us our Western society not just
America our populations the people who
vote do not know about that verse they
need to know it they need to Americans
the average American in schools
everywhere we need to know what that
doctrine is and understand why it's a
threat to us if we don't do that we
can't defend ourselves and that's a
different proposition from a Muslim
preformation Islam may or may not reform
I'm pointing out in heretic that there
is an opportunity for them to reform
that it's in our national interest to
side with and help those who are seeking
genuine change but when it comes to us
and preserving our rights preserving our
way of life we need overwhelming force
we need to understand what this is about
and we need to make this we can't just
say oh it's the fast amendments so you
can open an engine
urgency right in our midst we can't do
that
to do that is to go down the path of
Europe France today gentlelady's and
gentlemen of France is in a state of
emergency do you know what emergency law
means this is France they started after
the 13 November attacks and they just
extended it and they are writing it into
the Constitution is that where we want
to go so I think the time for this
wonderful sweet-talking multiculturalist
business is gone
I'd like you to explain the term that
I've heard many many times which is
called moderate Muslims and also if
we're arming so-called moderate Muslims
are we going to be fighting with her
against our own weapons in the future
okay so first of all I think the term
moderate Muslim or moderate Islam is
just as useless as saying the sky is
blue or some just think of any useless
time that just doesn't tell you anything
and serves to obscure the real problem I
think when you talk about your question
most specifically relates to Isis and
how we are responding to it and Syria
and that we are on the one hand being
told the rebels like Jeb Hatano Sarah
which is Al qaeda-affiliated is an
organization that we should give weapons
to against Isis I think that is
ridiculous
that just tells you over and over again
that our government and I'm not just
talking about the Obama administration
I'm talking about our entire elite they
just have a difficulty educating
themselves on these things
if you are in the State Department or in
the Department of Defense and you don't
know the difference between Giavotella
and Isis and why you shouldn't give
weapons to one or the other then you
shouldn't be in that job if you don't
understand what saudi arabia has done
and how they've spent billions about a
hundred billion u.s. dollars over three
or four decades in spreading the medina
agenda across the world including in our
own country then surely you should just
say I can't do this I'm going to do
something else instead what we have done
is the intelligence community after 9/11
when they started to really analyze the
threat those who linked it to Islam and
found their way to the doctrine they
were purged they were fired their lives
was made impossible I think we need to
bring those people back we need to
apologize to them and tell them do your
job and we will empower you and we are
citizens we need to elect
representatives that will do that that
understand the threat but to understand
the threat first and foremost means to
understand what the basic fundamentals
of this country are if you don't get it
you don't know what threatens it or not
okay Coop's thank you very much for
bringing this education to us I have a
question that's always confused me in
studying Islam and I'm a I'm fearful
that it may be stemming stemming right
at the very top of the government and
that is the concept and the I guess the
doctrine of takea I wish you might speak
to that thank you
the doctrine of takuya so if you are a
Medina and I'm going to try to be as
short as possible you are pushing a
Medina agenda not necessarily violent
but you understand that the use of
violence is something that you it's a
prudent it's a prudent thing but like
the Muslim Brotherhood you have a Medina
agenda you are a gradualist you want to
take your time about things you
understand for instance that these
Western governments at this point in
history are more powerful but you wants
to infiltrate like a termite and you've
got to tell these people what they want
to hear so the first thing you do and
every Muslim Brotherhood manual tells
their own people the same thing over and
over again you have to educate yourself
completely on the culture of these
people what they want to hear who they
are their principles and the short term
middle term and long term agendas tell
them what they want to hear so Tatia
is first of all it means caution it
means to act carefully imprudently and
at times you have to lie you are in the
West you are in America you see a
confrontation between the left and the
right if those times are meaningful at
all and you decide that it's the left is
probably more useful
and you just tell them what they want to
hear you push the right buttons when you
are talking to a Jewish man in New York
feeling very guilty raised the question
of the Holocaust and say that Muslims
today are in the same plight as Jews in
the 1930s say to the feminist who was
fighting sexism oh who thinks that she
is fighting sexism that the way women
were treated and felt inferior and
humiliated that's the way Muslims are
being treated tell the white man who
feels guilty for anything and everything
anyway push all those buttons and once
you've done that then put your agenda on
the table I want to open a Muslim Center
here I want to open a mosque there I
want to get homeschooling I want I want
I want and if you object then are you
not engaging in so that's a form of
Tatia
but takbir can also be literally lying
to your face somebody will tell you look
you in the eye and tell you
Muhammad only preached peace use your
intelligence
okay so III didn't hear the question I
didn't catch the question okay
please bring the mic to John okay
I have the mic here and I'd like to
welcome you to the greatest nation which
has ever been recognized in the world
you're a citizen I have been a citizen
for 50 years and sincerely welcome my
question is I'm a student of Islam I've
been what I have worked in the Muslim
world and the question came up in our
study group can devout and the key word
is devout Muslim become a US citizen as
we the people thank you very much can a
devout Muslim become a u.s. citizen well
a lot of thousands if not millions of
devout Muslims have been given
citizenship what you really want to know
is did you hear about the Boston
Marathon bombings
I hope you did the younger brother had
been given citizenship less than a year
before he decided that he wanted to kill
us and he wasn't that devout from the
background that I know the Times Square
bomber was given citizenship he came in
through a visa was given a city he was
living the American dream
can you become a citizen technically you
can be accorded citizenship but whether
you are born here whether you are a
convert or whether you are born to a
Muslim family you can be as devout as
you like what we need to know is are you
pursuing a Medina agenda and that means
you have to know
fellow citizens what happened in Medina
what Mohammed did in Medina and why all
the people that we've called radicals
invoke Medina if you don't know that and
you're sitting at the Department of
Homeland Security and you're giving out
these citizenships because somebody
tells you what you want to hear then you
are bringing us in danger you're not
doing your job well that's what we need
to know the classification of moderates
radical violent extremists that's
useless that's useless if you don't
understand the Medina agenda and why
it's invoked cite Farook here in San
Bernardino and his wife the way she was
covered what she was saying on social
media that could have alerted the
intelligence community to the fact that
this is not a person who should have
been given a visa but we did it anyway
it's not because they are strong or
because they are better it's because we
are being stupid
we have time for one last question thank
you so much for coming here tonight I'm
Joan kurta Posse from Stockton
California and I live on a farm and
about two or three miles down the road
they're building a mosque and it's been
in the process for two or three years
and it concerns me because I don't know
what they're going to educate these
people in and I need some advice on
maybe you've already given the advice
that are they Mecca or are they Medina
and what are they going to teach these
citizens that live in our area it
concerns me because I don't want the
girls to think that they're second-class
citizens well I think the first thing is
to find out who is building the mosque
where is the money coming from
are they connected to a chain of I mean
think about the Islamic centers and
mosques and the way they think read the
explanatory memorandum just google it
and you'll find it's in English the
Muslim Brotherhood in 1991 there was a
raid there was a case called the Holy
Land Foundation I don't know if you guys
are familiar with it or not but it's all
on the internet just google it Google
Muslim Brotherhood in America google the
explanatory memorandum at the bottom
there's a list of organizations that
they say are already well established
that they could father use the people
who are building that mosque are they a
part of that once you have all this
knowledge and you inform the rest of
your community and you really make the
rest of your community conscious about
what it is what are the principles that
you stand for why are you opposing this
mosque not because you're a racist not
because you're a bigot but because
ultimately you don't want this near you
because you understand citizens if you
organize grassroots and empower the
grassroots and I bet you
Muslims in your community who hates that
this mosque is coming and nobody's
listening to them nobody knows they
exist they are the modifiers these are
the guys we need to empower but it's a
long and hard fight and to this day I
just have to say the tragedy is there
they have been winning because there are
mosques and Muslim centers in every 50
states where girls and boys are
separated what you had is taught where
there's a lot of Dawa and they've done
it legally they've done it with the
consent of our leaders and with our
complacency thank you